let's look at chapter three
which covers norm and distance
so first we'll talk about norm norm is
the norm of a vector
is supposed to be a measure of its
length
um so we'll talk about that from that
we're allowed to talk about distance and
that's another topic that we'll cover
in this in this mini lecture
so the norm of a vector
and this is specifically a it's called a
euclidean norm
um in this course we're just going to
call it
the norm because it's the only norm
we're going to use there actually are
other norms that are actually
widely used but by far the most widely
used norm is
the one we're going to talk about the
euclidean norm here's what it is
it says there's an n vector x and the
norm which is denoted with these two
double bars on either side of x
i'll say something about that it's
supposed to generalize the absolute
value for a number
so okay and so the notation is meant to
look like it
so here it is it's the square root of
the sum of the squares
that is the norm of a vector and you can
write down if you like
as the square root of the inner product
of x
with itself so that's uh that's the norm
of a vector
and it's supposed to measure the size of
a vector
some people say the length unfortunately
the length of a vector is a little
ambiguous because it could either be n
in this case um or it could be the norm
so if you say size however it's probably
it probably means the uh
the the norm now when n is one
so it's a one vector which is by the way
the same as just a scalar
then the square root of the sum of the
squares is nothing but the square root
of the square
of the entry and that's the absolute
value right because when you square
something if it's negative or positive
you get the same number
when you take a square root we're taking
the positive square root or the
non-negative square root
so it's a generalization of the absolute
value to
vectors is what what that's the basic
idea it's supposed to give you the
length and
let's just do a quick example let's find
you know the
let's find the the norm of this vector
well that's going to be the square root
of
1 squared plus 0 squared plus 1 squared
and that's the square root of 2 which is
about one point you know
four one something like that about so
that's the length of a vector um okay
now there's a bunch of properties um
some of these are simple
uh one is not i'll say a little bit
about that later
so the first is homogeneity
and what this means is the following it
says that
if i take a vector and i scale all of
its entries by beta that means multiply
it
by the scalar vector multiplication beta
the norm of the result
is actually the absolute value of beta
times x
times the norm of x and that tells you a
lot of stuff already it says for example
that the norm of
x and the norm of minus x are the same
and you could figure that out too
because
if you if you replace all the entries x
i with negatives
and you square them you're back right
where you started so everything's
just the same um so that's the idea this
one is actually relatively easy to
to show because what happens is uh the
sum of the squares
each of those squares gets scaled by
beta squared but then they all come out
of the square root as a beta
absolute value made i should say okay um
the triangle inequality this one is is
interesting it's got a beautiful visual
uh visualization that we'll we'll show
later
um but we're not going to go into it now
i should also say it's not something
that's immediately easy
to see or something like that it would
take a paragraph or something to develop
but it's not hard
it just involves completing the square
i'm not going to do it here
you can read about it in the book or
something like that but this is the
but it's the so-called triangle
inequality it's very interesting it says
that the
the length of a sum of two vectors
is less than the sum of the lengths okay
now
i said that in english but it's the same
as overloading right
so the first sum was the sum of vectors
and the second sum was the sum of two
numbers
right so that's vector addition right
there and that
is addition of two non-negative numbers
so
um all right uh the next one is
non-negativity that that one is
extremely obvious because when you take
the sum of the squares of x you get a
non-negative number
that's good because you're thinking
they're going to take the square root
and if it were a negative number
it wouldn't be a good thing um so
and then of course the square root of
for us is defined as the non-negative
square root so that one's obvious this
one's interesting
definiteness this says that if if a norm
of a vector is zero
the only possible way that can happen is
it's zero that i
am going to say something about so let's
see what that means suppose
i told you that the norm of x is 0.
well that tells you that the norm of x
squared
is 0. but if the norm of x squared is 0
that's the same as x1 squared plus
plus x n squared that's sum okay
now if i tell you that a sum of numbers
is zero
you absolutely cannot conclude that they
are all zero
here's a nice example of that one and
minus one
their sum is zero they're obviously both
not zero
okay however if i tell you that a sum of
non-negative numbers
is zero then you can glue them then you
can conclude that all of them are zero
okay and that's easy to see if if the
numbers
are uh non-negative and one of them is
positive
then the whole sum is positive and if
you're positive you are not zero
so uh so what this says is from this
we can conclude that x i is equal to
zero
okay so that's the picture um
and the triangle inequality we'll we'll
see later
uh how how that works but um we'll also
see a picture of it that
that gives you know that explains the
name okay so these are some very basic
properties of the norm
um so far we haven't done anything with
a norm that would be even
vaguely of interest but we'll get there
okay
now very closely related quantity is
called the rms value
which stands for root mean square and so
let me explain what that is it's it's a
it's another measure of the size of a
of a vector so here um
the mean square value of a vector is the
sum it's the sum of the squares
right that would be the norm squared
divided by n and you can see what it is
it's the square of the entries and then
the mean of them
across the entries that's the mean
square and that is expressed in terms of
a norm as
norm squared x that's how you'd say that
divided by n
okay so that that's the mean square
value
what's very commonly used is something
called the rms value or
root mean square value um uh
it's used throughout engineering you
know
maybe in pure math i maybe somebody
would figure out what you're talking
about but it is used through absolutely
throughout engineering and many many
other fields there's rms value
here's what it is well it's literally
what its name says it's the square root
of the mean
square value so here that's the mean
square you take the square root
and you get it's actually equal to the
norm of x divided by square root n so
it's nothing more than the norm of x
divided by square root n
okay now the reason you would use this
is that it's going to it it actually
is more intuitive so what we'll see is
that the rms value of vector
gives roughly speaking something like
the typical value of the absolute value
of x i
i mean it doesn't but in a certain way
it does
right so um so
here's a good example is take the vector
of all ones right
and i ask you what is the what's the
norm of
ones well the norm of ones uh here i'll
make a bold one here
is actually the square root of n uh
where n is the length and
why because you would to get the norm
you would take the sum of the squares
the entries all the entries are 1
that gives you n and then you take the
square root so you get square root n
so and that's fine by the way if i'm
comparing norms of vectors always with
the same dimension
it does the square root n factor doesn't
matter right
um but if i show you a vector of ones
and i said
you know tell me about that vector one
seems like a natural thing to say that's
the rms value
and the reason that's a natural thing to
say is because all the entries are one
and so one is kind of telling you the
size of the individual entries right
so um rms value is also useful for
comparing
uh sizes of vectors of different lengths
right that that's actually very critical
right and we'll we'll see several
applications where you do exactly that
where you
you know you you take the rms value of
one size vector and another size vector
and now they're sort of comparable
uh this way okay so that's rms value
very widely uh used
you probably have seen it before it's
the most natural way to quote
uh let's say the the to give an idea of
the size of a vector
okay um one property and this is going
to come up later in the course
but we'll mention it now and that is
that that you can do the nor you can
calculate the normal block vectors in a
very uh simple way
um and what it is is this is
here here i have three vectors a b and c
um this is our notation that remember
that's a stacked vector
uh so i stack a on top of b on top of c
and i take the norm squared
well if you think about it how do i take
the norm squared
of uh of a a vector
it's the sum of the squares the entries
so i would first take the sum of the
squares of all the entries of a
i'd add that to the sum of the squares
of all the interest of b add that to all
the entries
and you'd get you can see this and you
can also see that by just multiplying
out the inner product
like this um and that says
it's and this is a very tricky formula
to parse so you have to be super duper
on your
toes um it says that the norm of the
block
vector here is equal to the following
it is the square root
of the norm squared of a plus a norm of
square root of b
plus the norm squared of c okay or we
can put it in
super compact and honestly very
confusing notation
but it does work okay so what this says
is
the the norm of a stacked vector
abc and of course i'm showing you stack
of three but it could be a stack of two
stack of 20 doesn't matter right um over
here what it says is that's the norm of
now these are numbers so a b and c the
norms of those those are three numbers
this is a three vector
in here that that's a three vector and
this is the norm of the three vector but
the norm of a three vector
is the square root of the sum of the
squares of the entries and that's
exactly what this is
so so we'll use these ideas that connect
uh norms
of stacked things uh later uh actually
we'll use it in the form that the
the norm squared of a stack thing is the
sum
of the norms squared of the entries
right that so this is really the one
that we're going to use later
so okay now we're going to talk about
the chebychev inequality
um and it's a famous inequality that
says it basically limits the number of
entries of a vector
that can be uh bigger than a certain
size
right um and that's the and that depends
on the norm
right so we'll look we'll look at how
that works and so the story starts this
way you say
um let's take the entries of a vector x1
through xn and let's consider their
absolute values
and suppose i told you that k of them
are bigger than or equal to some number
a
a could be whatever it doesn't 0.6 it
doesn't anything at all
okay all right well if if k
of those absolute values are bigger than
a then k of the numbers which are the
squares are bigger than a squared
okay now when i add up a bunch of
squares
and k of them are bigger than a squared
then the sum is better has got to be
bigger than k a
squared in fact it would only be ka
squared if
the other numbers the other n minus k
numbers are all zero
otherwise this is strict here it's even
bigger okay
but this is the norm squared of x it's
bigger than ka squared
and so what this says is i simply divide
by a squared and i get this
k is less than the norm squared of x
divided by a squared okay and so
what that says is basically it says that
the number
of entries of a vector that exceed an
absolute value
a number a is no more than
uh the norm squared of x squared norm
squared divided by a squared that's it
okay and that's that's his famous
chebychev inequality right that's
that's that's that's what it says um
and it's actually maybe clearer in terms
of rms value and this is the way
certainly normal people think of it
in terms of the rms value it's this
you divide appropriately by squared and
in the right place and everything and
here's what you get
it says if i have a vector x it says
that the fraction
of the entries with absolute value x
bigger than a is no more than
rms of x divided by a squared
so that's it um and
uh so let's let's look at some special
cases
i could take a equals the rms value
squared
um and it said it says
absolutely nothing it says the fraction
of entries of a vector
uh where the absolute value is bigger
than or equal to the rms value is bigger
than or equal to
uh one so okay fine um
okay however it gets interesting when a
is bigger than rms
of x right so for example uh
you could take five rms
uh something like that you know five
times rms of a and then it says
it says it's very it's very specific it
says
that no more than one then this is now
one-fifth
no more than one-fifth squared so
one-twenty-fifth so no more than four
percent of of the entries of a vector
can be bigger than five times the rms
value
okay so that's that's what it says um
and by the way this is kind of the idea
of of justifying
the idea that the rms value of a vector
is like the typical value of the entries
um
the entries can be bigger than the
typical value but they're
they're actually rather limited right
that you if you the number that can be
more than five times that number
is less than four percent of your total
vector so that's kind of the
that's the idea we'll see we'll see
applications of this
a bit later